master cellist david garingas and the
art vio ensemble are playing an evening
of exclusively lithuanian music
what do you want what do you want from
me
you want to dance with me
off we go
they have a reason to celebrate this
event falls right on the 25th
anniversary of lithuania's independence
it's a great chapter in our history it's
an important chapter
and i'm happy to be able to experience a
musical event like this in berlin
to remind us of it and give an overview
of what lithuania has to offer
the german finance ministry is
showcasing the variety of lithuanian
music in its series the sound of europe
martinez as he calls himself is 24 and
very popular among his countrymen he
started playing accordion at the age of
three as a teenager he was winning
competitions the world over
in 2010 he graduated from the royal
academy of music in london
now he divides his time between there
and vilnius the lithuanian capital
i play with quite a few orchestras back
home in lithuania and it happens fairly
often
and i'm very happy because it's
happening and it's it seems to be as a
very active musical cultural scene back
home in lithuania
lithuania with a population of just 3
million joined the european union in
2004.
vilnius is the center of its cultural
life
in 2009 the city was a european capital
of culture
another big step towards becoming part
of europe was introducing the euro at
the start of 2015
back in berlin it's clear that singing
is of great importance in lithuania
and right now singer-songwriter alina
oliva is enjoying great success
this special polyphone type of singing
known as sutatines is part of an
ages-old musical tradition in lithuania
since 2008 sutatinas has been recognized
by unesco as part of the world cultural
heritage
and vitaltes camillos is a virtuoso on
an instrument that also has a special
place in lithuanian culture the babina
is a wind instrument that's quite
similar to a clarinet
this instrument made from
wood
cowhorn
cow and the mastic-like clarinet
we we need to take
reeds
like clarinet
and that's all
it's verbena
national instrument
david garingas was able to study at the
moscow state conservatory in the soviet
union
still he's happy that nowadays young
lithuanian musicians have more
opportunities open to them
now everyone learns everywhere
since the berlin wall fell everything
has opened up
now the students don't just study in
lithuania moscow or saint petersburg
they study in berlin cologne london
paris and the us
and that brings with it a great variety
of influences
the sounds of lithuania resonate at the
german finance ministry
other countries will also make guest
appearances here in december it's
luxembourg's turn